it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you go to low Santos one
more time to relive the heist with
trevor franklin michael or just grab
your friends to rob people online
there's an all new director mode that
gives you the option to record your
antics at will and record it from the
perspective of almost anything in a
block radius of your character including
other heist members pedestrians even
animals you even get full control of the
audio right down to the songs on the
radio so expect amazing things from the
online community it's all going down on
the 14th oh but this week is so hot for
releases we got another big one Mortal
Kombat X is finally here so you can test
out sub-zero and scorpions brutalities
and fatalities for yourself the game
features two new types of finishing
moves there's quit ality which will
instantly kill a player's character if
they quit during a multiplayer match and
then there's faction kills finishing
moves tied to each of the games five
factions brutality finishing moves make
a comeback from Ultimate Mortal Kombat 3
and they're triggered with unknown moves
but if you can get it they give you the
last attack and the round crack some
skulls on the fourteenth and this week
isn't done yet because the Beast is
finally released from his cage and into
the wild fields of Xbox one that's right
goat simulator is making its debut on
current-gen Xbox to satisfy all your
goat needs showcased in this trailer
that shows absolutely zero gameplay
don't know what you're buying who cares
tell here's footage of goat simulator in
dota 2 it's pretty much this level of
silliness
get goaded April seventeenth also this
week a sweet shadow of the colossus
inspired game makes its debut on
playstation 4 Vita and PC Titan Souls
puts you in the body of a tiny little
hunter with a tiny little arrow out to
kill giant Titans that stand in his way
he's got to gather their souls in a
quest for truth and power there's
nothing in this game but straight up
badass boss fights and you can be killed
in one hit so you got to get your role
on a name with purpose it's not bad
looking either in the foreboding music
drives you to your next battle with hope
and fear for what looms ahead it's damn
good people so give the demo a try if
you're on the fence it's out on the 14th
Vita owners get block sick this week a
3d cube color matching puzzle game 100
unique levels across seven different
worlds will add other elements like
locked cubes moving cubes bomb cubes
some other cube type of cube this
Rubik's esque game can be snagged for 10
bucks on the 14th we already talked
about grand theft auto 5 for pc but i
worked on this peep diorama and i really
want to show it off so these are all the
games coming out this week for further
details visit gamespot.com release
states are based on retailer listings
and are subject to change see you next
week
member